Here are five things to know about neural
networks in under five minutes. Number one:
neural networks are composed of node layers. There
is an input node layer, there is a hidden layer,
and there is an output layer. And these neural
networks reflect the behavior of the human brain,
allowing computer programs to recognize patterns
and solve common problems in the fields of AI and
deep learning. In fact, we should be describing
this as an artificial neural network, or anANN,
to distinguish it from the very un-artificial
neural network that's operating in our heads. Now,
think of each node, or artificial neuron, as its own
linear regression model. That's number two.
Linear regression is a mathematical model that's
used to predict future events. The weights of the
connections between the nodes determines how much
influence each input has on the output. So each
node is composed of input data, weights, a bias,
or a threshold, and then an output. Now data is
passed from one layer in the neural network to the
next in what is known as a feed forward network --
number three. To illustrate this, let's consider
what a single node in our neural network might
look like to decide -- should we go surfing. The
decision to go or not is our predicted outcome
or known as our yhat. Let's assume there are
three factors influencing our decision. Are the
wave's good, 1 for yes or 0 for no.  The waves
are pumping, so x1 equals 1, 1 for yes.  Is the
lineup empty, well unfortunately not, so that gets a
0. And then let's consider is it shark-free out
there, that's x3 and yes, no shark attacks have
been reported. Now to each decision we assign a
weight based on its importance on a scale of 0
to 5. So let's say that the waves, we're going to
score that one, eh, so this is important, let's
give it a 5. And for the crowds, that's w2.
Eh, not so important, we'll give that a 2.
And sharks, well, we'll give that a score of a
4. Now we can plug in these values into the
formula to get the desired output. So yhat equals
(1 * 5) + (0 * 2) + (1 * 4), then
minus 3, that's our threshold, and that gives us
a value of 6. Six is greater than 0, so the
output of this node is 1 -- we're going surfing.
And if we adjust the weights or the threshold,
we can achieve different outcomes.
Number four. Well, yes, but but but number four, neural networks
rely on training data to learn and improve their
accuracy over time. We leverage supervised learning
on labeled datasets to train the algorithm.
As we train the model, we want to evaluate its
accuracy using something called a cost function.
Ultimately, the goal is to minimize our cost function to
ensure the correctness of fit for any given
observation, and that happens as the model adjusts
its weights and biases to fit the training data
set, through what's known as gradient descent,
allowing the model to determine the direction
to take to reduce errors, or more specifically,
minimize the cost function. And then finally,
number five: there are multiple types of neural
networks beyond the feed forward neural network
that we've described here. For example, there are
convolutional neural networks, known as CNNs, which
have a unique architecture that's well suited
for identifying patterns like image recognition.
And there are recurrent neural networks, or RNNs,
which are identified by their feedback loops and
RNNs are primarily leveraged using time series
data to make predictions about future events like
sales forecasting.  So, five things in five minutes.
To learn more about neural networks, check out these videos.
Thanks for watching.
If you haveany questions, please drop us a line below. And
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future, please Like and Subscribe.